one small thing yeah when you bring me
out can you introduce me as Joker hello
friends and welcome back to the show
I'm mark Ellison yes I'm enjoying my
beard as well if you see over here it's
a lot of our friends and they're all
Joker's but who's missing that's right
little Arthur Fleck and boy did the
internet comments let us know that
Arthur Fleck should be right at the top
of the list my decision last year was
that mark Hamill's the best Joker of all
time but we here at the show decided
we'd put me in a really fancy jacket
that cost tens of dollars in the
neighborhood thrift store and we're
gonna put our through flicking all those
rounds that I put all these guys through
last year and see where he comes out
after that we're gonna come right back
here and I'm gonna read some viewer
comment from the internet
I'm gonna read Internet comments on the
air pray for me here's how Arthur Fleck
does in all of our rounds from the
previous bit when it was announced that
a standalone Joker backstory film was in
production fans were curious questions
like who's playing Batman and does this
connect to Justice League were asked and
the answer was this is a joker film
about bat guy no one else it's his story
and it's not gonna cost a lot of money
from a production budget of around sixty
million dollars the film has gone on to
gross three hundred and thirty four
million dollars domestically and a
billion dollars internationally putting
this Joker in the conversation for most
profitable clown in history alongside
penny wise and Ronald McDonald more
importantly for our purposes it places
him fourth domestically amongst films
that featured a joker at the top is the
Dark Knight with six hundred sixty nine
million dollars and Joker is second
place internationally once again
trailing only the Dark Knight those are
the only two Joe cream movies to cross
the magic billion dollar box-office mark
it's okay I'm a good guy in terms of the
tomato meter mr. flex film is a little
lower than it's award season Hall might
indicate it's fresh at 69% but that's
only good for sixth place when it comes
to flicks featuring a joker the only two
films that are lower than that are
Batman The Killing Joke at 40% and the
oscar-winning Suicide Squad at 27% yes
The Dark Knight tops all the films once
again at 94%
tomato meter hello beautiful so while
Joker is fresh and crushed at the box
office it wouldn't be enough to top this
round down to most memorable now Arthur
has a shot
the haunting performance of Joaquin
Phoenix stays with you long after the
lights have come back on the tragedy of
how this person succumbed to madness and
then embracing that dark side it's just
so compelling and it reached a depth of
emotion we have not seen from a Joker
the previous winner of this round was
Jack Nicholson's Joker and as memorable
as he was it was a fun good time kind of
memory Arthur Fleck is a living
nightmare and it makes the audience feel
like we're experiencing his downfall in
subsequent rebirth right there with him
what's even more confounding is that the
amount of sympathy that we are feeling
for this character it was funny to laugh
at Jack's one-liners but no one felt
sorry for him we weren't rooting for
that Joker we wanted Batman to win but
by the end of this new Joker I was
relieved that he didn't have to face an
adult Batman because I don't know whose
side I'd be on if it was me dying on the
sidewalk you'd walk right over me why
keen Phoenix gave the performance of a
lifetime and for that I can confidently
say he wins this round
[Music]
round three most dastardly plans the
Joker's have had all sorts of
Harebrained Schemes some were
diabolically genius others were
ridiculously goofy and most were a
combination of the two
however this joker isn't really a
schemer for most of the movie he wants
some answers from people like Thomas
Wayne any dreams of one day being a
successful Canadian but I don't think
those qualifies dastardly plans he does
cook up one intensely brutal plan and
pulls it off on live television his
subsequent popularity amongst Gotham's
dejected denizens might inspire Arthur
to drum up more Joker II plotz but if
we're just sticking to the events of
this film I'm gonna keep Cesar Romero as
the most dastardly planner so Joaquin
does have a point so far and with all
the award buzz and dolla dolla bills
this movie's generated I'd say he's in a
conversation for most iconic Joker ever
his biggest advantage screen time he's
in virtually every scene in the movie
because he's the star
there's no Batman to compete with so he
has all the time in the world to
permanently implant himself in our minds
as the quintessential Joker the problem
is this film is by design a different
Joker than we've ever seen before sure
there's similar angles to things we've
seen on screen or read in the comics the
failed comedian pathos the flashy suit
the lack of guilt from murdering humans
and the real issue with this Joker being
an icon is it there isn't that elite
competition that all the other ones have
benefited from mr. Batman Bruce Wayne is
still a kid sucking down ecto cooler
than Joker and so Arthur Fleck never
gets the chance to show us just what a
super villain he can be so is this Joker
iconic yes but I don't think he's quite
the icon of deep Ledger's or Mark
Hamill's Joker but again that's just my
opinion many outlets have rated Arthur
Fleck right alongside the most
celebrated Joker's ever our expert
researcher Mark Hoffmeyer went through
15 different Joker rankings that were
updated to include this latest
incarnation and guess what
Joaquin's finished in second place
trailing Ola Heath Ledger and edging out
Mark Hamill that's not the way I see it
but I'm just a silly host with a great
beard it's playing well I know
are you sure about that look in the
mirror let's turn it over to you the
fans right now who do you think was the
best Joker to ever put on the makeup I'm
gonna read some comments live on the air
let's get to the viewer comments thanks
Internet go
spitting ink says if this vid was done
now Joker 2019 would have won the first
round ah wrong sir
wrong that was tomato meter and box
office so while Joker did very well on
both those things it was not the top
Joker could not have given Joaquin that
round
nobody's civil anymore look pretty much
every Joker got love which is why y'all
are so great sentient number six says
Romero hands down best Joker ever
I like your nostalgia and we also had
someone actually say Jared Leto is the
best Joker but then they started
laughing hmm that's not nice
it really did come down to Mark Hamill
vs. Heath Ledger
I deserve respect so here's what team
Hamill had to say anytime someone
mentions the Joker's name I immediately
can hear that amazing laughter that Mark
Hamill provides Mark Hamill takes a
number one spot in my book yeah we we
read the same book and then team Leger
responded Heath was so good he convinced
me that Gotham is a real city and all it
has was real rest of the Joker's were
fiction hmm yeah I pretty much believe
Gotham's a real place both in the Dark
Knight trilogy particularly the Dark
Knight and in this new Joker that got
them I'm moving there were some people
that wanted compromise Heath for
live-action Mark for animated I agree
with that
Heath it was the best live-action mark
was the best animated but it's my job I
had to pick one and let's face it if I
did one vid for live-action Joker's and
one for animated chokers you know I'd
have to do another vid for the best
Joker of all time I just I cut out the
middleman and I picked Marc and some
people naturally had things to say about
your host the guy talking right now
Tobias says sorry but the guy doing the
show is so much fun
like a salesman at a car store kills the
whole show I can't tell if that's is
that killing like oh man this guy's
killing it that's how I'm taking it to
bias that's how I'm sleeping tonight hey
thank all of you for your comments on
the video we did last year and now I
would love to see your comments on this
video flick is he all the way at the top
now that you've seen the Joker or is he
somewhere under Mark Hamill is the above
Jack Nicholson give us your updated
rankings like I just did appreciate you
all watching the show I'm Mark Ellis and
I promise this year no French tux
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]